احتجاجات هي الاكبر في ايران صوتها صدح
داخليا وخارجيا تحت الدمعه قمع نظام
العنيف للتصدي المتظاهرين بعضهم وصل حد
الترهيب الاخطر كان ما يتعرض له المعتقلون
منهم الاجراءات ومحاكمات سريعه زادت معها
مخاوف اصدار وتنفيذ احكام الحرابه
للمواطنين بمن فيهم الاطفال
حيث شرع سياسيون في مختلف انحاء اوروبا في
رعايه المحتاجين الايرانيين المسجونين على
امل ان تطر السلطات عبر تصويت الضوء على
حاله الظلم الفرديه للعدول عن اصدار احكام
بالسجن فترات طويله او تنفيذ احكام
بالاعدام هناك ما يصل الى 30 ايضا قيد
الاحتجاج الان ممن لديه مراعي اوروبي
في المانيا قضيه الطفله الايرانيه سونيا
الشريفي ذات 16 عاما والتي قد تواجه عقوبه
الاعدام كذلك ما ارتبدنا حاله محمد بروكلي
19 عاما يواجه الاعدام الوشيك في سجن رجاء
شهر في مدينه كرج اضافه الى مغني الراب
المعارض المعتقل الصالحي وارميت عباسي ذات
العشرين عاما التي نقلتها قوه الامن الى
مستشفى في كرج بعد تعرضها لاصابات متعدده
من السجناء السياسيين في الماضي فاذا
مصطفى
على يد الحرس الثوري في فرنسا
المهدد بالاعدام في اي لحظه فيما دعت
نائبه فرنسيه لاطلاق صلاح الشقيقين
الخطر ضد النظام الايراني المهدد بعزله
دوليه فمن الانتفاضه قتل ما لا يقل عن 63
طفلا على ايدي قوه الامن وفقا لاحصائيات
منظمات حقوقيه ايرانيه في معتقل الاف
المواطنين خلال التظاهرات في مدن مختلفه
بينهما عدد كبير من الاطفال والمراهقين